if rules exist we'll find a way around
them and even Pokemon go is no exception
players everywhere have found ways to
bend or break the game's rules some of
these methods are fairly harmless whilst
others can get you banned here's how to
cheat in Pokemon go but don't say we
didn't warn you
egg hatching machines are you too tired
or lazy to walk around and hatch those
eggs you've had forever no problem just
use something else to do it for you
creative Pokemon go players have come up
with all sorts of ways to hatch their
eggs without also working the glutes
some trainers have even started
strapping their phones to the actual
real-life pets before sending them
outside to play others use spinning
household objects like turntables
bicycle wheels and even ceiling fans to
do the work of course don't use the
spinning plate on your microwave for
this method
despite the memes floating around
showing you a phone safely spinning
inside a microwave if you do this all
you'll end up with is a broken warranty
some dead Pikachu's and a very
disappointed dad
stealing gems after a gym attack brings
its prestige down to zero it becomes
neutral until a player places a new
Pokemon in as a defender that may take a
few moments because players can only use
a fully healed Pokemon as defenders if
you don't have creatures that are strong
enough to take over a gym yet those few
seconds are your opportunity watch for
the gym to turn neutral then immediately
tap on it and place one of your Pokemon
in there as a defender next go to your
shop menu and tap the shield icon to
claim your daily defender bonus of Poker
coins and Stardust you'll claim a gym
without having to attack even once who
needs friends when you have imaginary
dust pick your eeveelution when you
evolve an Eevee in Pokemon go it can
turn into one of three different forms
seemingly at random if you want some
control however name them after the
original Eevee trainers from the Pokemon
car
turn naming your Eevee Sparky will get
you a Jolteon Rayna will get you a
Vaporeon and pyro will get you a Flareon
you may need to restart your app after
naming your Eevee before proceeding with
the evolution process and remember you
can always change those ducky names to
something way cooler later GPS spoofing
put simply GPS spoofing is making your
device pretend to be at a location that
you are not some trainers like popular
youtuber PewDiePie have gone to some
extreme lengths to do this like
strapping their phone to a
remote-controlled drone and flying it
around whilst playing the game via their
laptop at home technologically savvy
cheaters can also install a program
called BlueStacks on their computer
which creates a virtual Android
environment on the PC that acts just
like a phone after routing the device
they can install a modified version of
Pokemon go as well as a GPS baking app
once everything is set up cheetahs can
set their location via the fake GPS app
on the device open up Pokemon go and
then play the game without leaving home
if you want to know more you're probably
a bad person early reports indicate that
most cheaters who are being found out
are only being given a soft band locking
them out of the game for an arrow to it
the most but there are also more and
more reports of permanent vans so play
fair or get kicked out of Pokemon for
all eternity stupid idiots lemme in a
crappy Club for jerk thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what you think of Pokemon go
cheetahs